Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Yee-haw! Not since Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid first rode the planes in search of trains to Rob has a double act resonated with its audience quite like Tom Holland and me, Dominic Sandbrook. When they come to make the film of The Rest Is History,
感谢收听《历史的余味》。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。嘿！自从布奇·卡西迪和圣丹斯小子第一次骑马在平原上寻找火车去抢劫以来，还没有哪对搭档能像汤姆·霍兰德和我，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克这样引起观众的共鸣。当他们要拍摄《历史的余味》电影时，
as they surely will, Tom Holland will be played by an aging Clint Eastwood. And by a miracle of science, they'll bring back a youthful CGI Robert Redford to take on my role. It does say Yul Brunner. It does say Yul Brunner in the script, but I don't want to say that.
正如他们肯定会做的那样，汤姆·霍兰德将由老年的克林特·伊斯特伍德扮演。而通过科学奇迹，他们会带回年轻的 CGI 版罗伯特·雷德福来扮演我的角色。剧本里确实写的是尤尔·伯连纳。剧本里确实写的是尤尔·伯连纳，但我不想说那个。
Gene Hackman, I think. Well, what I usually get is the fellow who played Tony Soprano. I can't remember what his name is. James Galdofini. Whenever he appears on the screen, my wife kind of looks at me
我想是吉恩·哈克曼。嗯，我通常得到的是扮演托尼·索普拉诺的那位。我不记得他叫什么名字了。詹姆斯·甘多菲尼。每当他出现在屏幕上，我妻子就会看着我，
and she says, don't you feel that's a bit weird? You're just staring at yourself on the screen. Anyway, the movie will end according to the script with a pair of us
然后她说，你不觉得这有点奇怪吗？你只是在屏幕上盯着你自己看。总之，电影将按照剧本以我们俩
looking out from a cave at a host of gun-toting historians. This is quality script work, isn't it? Dan Snow, their grizzled leader. And we'll smile, nod at each other, and then burst forth in a blaze of glory.
从洞穴里向外望去，看着一群持枪的历史学家而结束。这是高质量的剧本创作，不是吗？丹·斯诺，他们灰白头发的领袖。我们会微笑，互相点头，然后在一片荣耀的光辉中冲出去。
This is great stuff, isn't it, Tom? I like that. Yeah. Let's just run with this. Well, clearly. I mean, we don't write these introductions. Our producer writes them. And they're great, as you can tell.
这太棒了，不是吗，汤姆？我喜欢这个。是的。我们就按这个来吧。嗯，很明显。我的意思是，我们不写这些介绍。我们的制片人写的。而且它们很棒，正如你所见。
Well, welcome to The Rest Is History. And today's topic for the avoidance of doubt is the Wild West. So the era of gunslinging, cattle ranching, lasso throwing, madams, bordellos, stagecoaches, the Pony Express, the Indian Wars, and the expansion of European settlers across the American continent. Tom Holland, you're a big Wild West fan. This was your idea, so you must be. I am. Well, I'm a fan of the Wild West as a myth. I'm not going to pretend to have any great specialist knowledge about it. continent tom holland you're a big wild west fan this was your idea so you must be i am a well i'm
欢迎来到《历史的余味》。为了避免疑虑，今天的主题是狂野西部。也就是那个充满枪战、牧牛、套索、老鸨、妓院、驿站马车、小马快递、印第安战争以及欧洲定居者在美洲大陆扩张的时代。汤姆·霍兰德，你是狂野西部的忠实粉丝。这是你的主意，所以你一定是。我是。嗯，我是作为神话的狂野西部的粉丝。我不会假装对此有任何伟大的专业知识。大陆汤姆·霍兰德你是狂野西部的忠实粉丝这是你的主意所以你一定是我是嗯我是
a fan of the wild west as a myth um i'm not going to pretend to any great specialist knowledge about it but um i've been out west i've been to wyoming i've been to montana i've visited the site of the battle of the little bighorn so um i'm kind of i'm i'm a fan i guess that's a long way to go tom why was what what brought you out there that's not an obvious destination for a classical historian well i went there because i'm very interested in dinosaurs um and i don't want to measure too much in this because perhaps we could we could do a separate podcast on dinosaurs but um the the the um the 1870s 1880s was the golden age of paleontology in the wild west it's absolutely full of bone fields so i basically went out to
作为神话的狂野西部的粉丝，嗯，我不会假装对此有任何伟大的专业知识，但是，嗯，我去过西部，我去过怀俄明州，我去过蒙大拿州，我参观过小大角战役的遗址，所以，嗯，我算是，我算是，我是一个粉丝，我想那是一个很远的地方，汤姆，是什么，是什么把你带到那里的？那对古典历史学家来说不是一个显而易见的目的地。嗯，我去那里是因为我对恐龙非常感兴趣，嗯，我不想在这里谈论太多，因为也许我们可以，我们可以做一个关于恐龙的单独播客，但是，嗯，1870年代、1880年代是狂野西部古生物学的黄金时代，那里绝对到处都是骨头场，所以我基本上是去
look at the paleontological museums but it's absolutely woven in with the history of the wild west so um there's this place called medicine bow which was um a stop on the railroad just after it had you know transcontinental railroad had opened up um and a huge quarry just north of medicine bow is where they found the first uhropod, so a huge long-tailed, long-necked dinosaur. But Medicine Bow is also the place where the shootout takes place in Owen Wister's novel, The Virginian, which in a way is the kind of... The great Western novel, yeah. Yeah, it's the foundational Western novel with, you know, the shootout, the saloon, all that kind of stuff. So it kind of stuff so um so it kind of it interwove and and um you know being in in uh
看古生物博物馆，但它绝对与狂野西部的历史交织在一起，所以，嗯，有一个叫医药弓的地方，它是，嗯，铁路上的一个站点，就在它，你知道，横贯大陆铁路开通之后，医药弓北面一个巨大的采石场就是他们发现第一只蜥脚类恐龙的地方，也就是一种巨大的长尾、长颈恐龙。但医药弓也是欧文·威斯特的小说《弗吉尼亚人》中发生枪战的地方，这在某种程度上是那种……伟大的西部小说，是的。是的，它是基础性的西部小说，有，你知道，枪战、沙龙，所有那些东西。所以它，所以它，它交织在一起，而且，嗯，你知道，在，在，嗯
in montana and being in wyoming of course i was going to go visit the site of the battle of little bighorn because that's an amazing story as well and i think that um in a way characters like custer and sitting bull and crazy horse for me they have the resonance of homeric heroes i mean they these are these are figures who are larger than life and and who in a sense kind of exist beyond the dimension of history almost yes um homeric heroes but but tom don't you think that we're probably the last generation of whom that's true i mean i grew up in 70s britain and cowboy films on tv and i remember i had a brilliant picture book an italian picture book translated translated into English, called Ernest and the Wild West. But a fellow called Ernest, and he meets Calamity Jane, and he goes on steamships, and he meets Sitting Bull and Custer,
在蒙大拿州，在怀俄明州，我当然要去参观小大角战役的遗址，因为那也是一个了不起的故事，而且我认为，嗯，在某种程度上，像卡斯特、坐牛和疯马这样的角色，对我来说，他们有荷马史诗英雄的共鸣，我的意思是，这些人是超越生活的人物，而且在某种意义上，他们几乎存在于历史维度之外。是的，嗯，荷马史诗英雄，但是，汤姆，你不觉得我们可能是最后一代认为这是真的的人吗？我的意思是，我在70年代的英国长大，电视上有牛仔电影，我记得我有一本很棒的图画书，一本翻译成英语的意大利图画书，叫《欧内斯特和狂野西部》。但是一个叫欧内斯特的家伙，他遇到了灾星简，他乘坐蒸汽船，他遇到了坐牛和卡斯特，
and it ends at the Battle of Little Bighorn. But you don't really see that in pop culture today to the same extent, do you? I wonder if you're 20 or if you're 10, you know, stories about, as it were, cowboys and Indians have the same resonance as they did for us and for our parents. I think that's almost certainly true. And I think that one of the reasons why the Wild West is so fascinating as a topic of historical inquiry
它以小大角战役结束。但你今天在流行文化中并没有真正看到这一点，对吧？我想知道如果你20岁或者10岁，你知道，关于，所谓的，牛仔和印第安人的故事是否像对我们和我们的父母那样有同样的共鸣。我认为这几乎肯定是正确的。而且我认为狂野西部作为一个历史探究主题之所以如此迷人，原因之一
is that the myth itself is profoundly influential as a fact of history. And in a way, it's a kind of lightning rod for so much that is being debated and contested in america at the moment because of course what makes it gripping and fascinating as a theater for narrative is also what makes it kind of terrifying because this is a place of violence and aggression and um kind of unmediated confrontation between whether it's um native americans and settlers or cattle rustlers
是神话本身作为历史事实具有深远的影响力。在某种程度上，它是目前美国正在辩论和争论的许多问题的避雷针，因为当然，使它作为叙事舞台引人入胜和迷人的东西，也是使它变得有点可怕的东西，因为这是一个充满暴力和侵略的地方，嗯，无论是美洲原住民和定居者，还是偷牛贼
and vigilantes or whatever um these are all very very contested areas and i think one of one of the things about the wild west that perhaps even more than the question of race and of indigenous rights is the fact that it is very, very masculine. Yeah, it is. And of course, it's huge in playing, creating American masculinity, isn't it? Basically, the image of the cowboy and the macho frontiersman in the classic i mean even in even in the virginian um the virginian is kind of tamed by uh an east coast school mom and that there's a very kind of you know the ambivalence towards the feminizing instinct runs throughout all these kind of narratives and indeed through through the authentic history as well i think so i think that it's it's it's a it's a hugely contested and i guess the word is problematic oh don't go there i didn't i didn't do this podcast
和治安维持者，或者其他什么，嗯，这些都是非常、非常受争议的领域，而且我认为关于狂野西部的一件事，也许甚至比种族和原住民权利问题更重要，那就是它非常、非常男性化。是的，确实。当然，它在塑造美国男性气质方面非常重要，不是吗？基本上，牛仔和马乔边疆人的形象在经典中，我的意思是即使在《弗吉尼亚人》中，嗯，弗吉尼亚人被一个东海岸的学校女教师驯服了，而且有一种非常，你知道，对女性化本能的矛盾心理贯穿了所有这些叙事，实际上也贯穿了真实的历史，我认为是这样，所以我认为这是一个，这是一个，这是一个非常受争议的，我想这个词是“有问题的”。哦，别提那个，我没有，我没有做这个播客
to talk about i know i knew that that would prompt you to get you you've triggered me tom you've triggered you let's let's rewind a bit and and talk before we get into the myth let's talk a little bit about the history so um you'll be delighted to know that, of course, that there's a religious element to this story. So it feels remiss not to start with this question from Rory Martin. He says, Tom, you love Christianity's impact on the West. You're not wrong, Rory. How do you explain the influence of manifest destiny
来谈论，我知道，我知道那会促使你，你触发了我，汤姆，你触发了你，让我们，让我们倒带一点，在进入神话之前，让我们谈谈历史。所以，嗯，你会很高兴知道，当然，这个故事有一个宗教元素。所以如果不从罗里·马丁的这个问题开始，感觉就失职了。他说，汤姆，你热爱基督教对西部的影响。你没说错，罗里。你如何解释天命论的影响
and the city-on-a-hill the Western Expansion of the United States. So do you want to say a little bit about that? Well, I guess that in a sense, the moment that English settlers land on the shores of North America, they're dealing with a Western frontier, aren't they? Yeah. I mean, you know, the moment you step onto Plymouth Rock, everything west is a frontier from you. And of course, those early settlers are very motivated by the idea that they're living out the Book of Exodus, that they've been given a promised land. And that, of course, is a part of what drives people westwards. But shockingly, I don't think it's the same thing.
和山巅之城，美国的西部扩张。所以你想谈谈那个吗？嗯，我想在某种程度上，当英国定居者登陆北美海岸的那一刻，他们就在处理一个西部边疆，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，你知道，当你踏上普利茅斯岩的那一刻，西边的一切对你来说都是边疆。当然，那些早期的定居者非常受这种想法的激励，即他们正在实践《出埃及记》，他们被赋予了一片应许之地。当然，这也是驱使人们向西的一部分原因。但令人震惊的是，我不认为这是同一回事。
This is very unusual yeah so i think one of the one of the fascinations of the west is that um it's it's clearly essentially driven by by greed i think i mean it's it's it's a need for land it's it's a need for for for fur i mean you know to begin with it's it's the desire for trapping that leads them down these rivers, killing all the beavers. I do think that, of course, religion plays a huge part in the narrative of the West. The figure of the preacher is an absolute kind of standard. And I think also that when you look at Native American responses to it, the influence of christianity is fairly huge so um right at the end of of um the wild west period the kind of the tragic story of the ghost dance the ghost dance that's an amazing story where native americans are are suffused with a kind of distorted sense
这非常不寻常，是的，所以我认为西部的迷人之处之一是，嗯，它显然本质上是由贪婪驱动的，我想，我的意思是，它是，它是，它是对土地的需求，它是对毛皮的需求，我的意思是，你知道，首先，它是对捕猎的渴望，导致他们沿着这些河流，杀死了所有的海狸。我确实认为，当然，宗教在西部的叙事中扮演了巨大的角色。传教士的身影绝对是一种标准。而且我认为，当你观察美洲原住民对此的反应时，基督教的影响也相当大，所以，嗯，就在狂野西部时期的末尾，那种悲剧性的鬼舞故事，鬼舞，那是一个了不起的故事，美洲原住民被一种扭曲的感官所充斥
of the christian apocalyptic uh you know they have this idea you know they're living among the absolute ruins of their world and the ghost dance is this kind of messianic message that if they dance then the white men will will vanish will be kind of buried beneath five foot of soil and the buffalo will come back the buffalo have been wiped out and with the destruction of the buffalo the whole native american way of life has been destroyed and that um all the native americans who are dead will come back to life. And it's kind of terribly, painfully tragic reworking of the Christian story. But, of course, the fact that it does have this Christian element that has been brought by the settlers show that the kind of stark division between rival sides is simplistic. Because the West is a hugely contested area.
基督教末日论，嗯，你知道，他们有这种想法，你知道，他们生活在他们世界的绝对废墟中，而鬼舞是一种弥赛亚式的信息，如果他们跳舞，那么白人就会消失，会被埋在五英尺的土壤之下，水牛就会回来，水牛已经被消灭了，随着水牛的毁灭，整个美洲原住民的生活方式也被摧毁了，而且，嗯，所有死去的原住民都会复活。这是一种非常、痛苦地悲剧性地重塑基督教故事的方式。但是，当然，它确实有这种由定居者带来的基督教元素，这表明敌对双方之间的那种鲜明划分是简单化的。因为西部是一个非常受争议的地区。
And I think that despite talking about the influence of Christianity on the West, actually in the classic period, what's telling about it is the lack of Christian morals. I mean, this is an era where the shootout is an authentic fact of Wild West history. That really happened. It is a world sort of steeped in violence, isn't it, from the very beginning? I mean, there's a couple of sort of stats. I know we don't really happened. It is a world sort of steeped in violence, isn't it, from the very beginning?
而且我认为，尽管谈论了基督教对西部的影响，实际上在古典时期，令人说明问题的是基督教道德的缺失。我的意思是，这是一个枪战是狂野西部历史中真实事实的时代。那真的发生了。这是一个从一开始就沉浸在暴力中的世界，不是吗？我的意思是，有几个统计数据。我知道我们没有真的发生了。这是一个从一开始就沉浸在暴力中的世界，不是吗？
I mean, there's a couple of sort of stats. I know we don't really normally do stats and facts. We've got a fact-free history podcast. But, you know, people argue about how many Indians there were at the beginning when the first sort of settlers arrived in North America. But there were probably – I mean, the estimates vary massively. But let's say there were between 5 and 10 million.
我的意思是，有几个统计数据。我知道我们通常不做统计和事实。我们有一个无事实的历史播客。但是，你知道，人们争论当第一批定居者到达北美时有多少印第安人。但可能——我的意思是，估计数字差异巨大。但假设有500万到1000万之间。
But by 1890 or so, there were 250,000. So a colossal decline in just a short time. But an even more shocking figure, actually, which I only found this morning when I was swatting up for this podcast, is that in the late 18th century, there were 60 million bison in North America. And in 1889, there were 541. So as you say, the bison, which the Native Americans depended on the bison, they had this kind of symbiotic relationship. And when the bison were
但到了1890年左右，只有25万了。所以在很短的时间内出现了巨大的下降。但一个更令人震惊的数字，实际上，我今天早上在为这个播客做准备时才发现，在18世纪末，北美有6000万头野牛。而在1889年，只有541头。所以正如你所说，美洲原住民依赖的野牛，他们有这种共生关系。当野牛被
destroyed, their world just completely fell apart. And the story of this, which basically is not the story that we got as children, is just the utter extermination. And extermination is the word. I mean, American generals talk about exterminating the Indians quite freely, and their men behave often with appalling savagery. That's really the sort of story that is still slightly obscured by the romantic myths, isn't it? Well, oddly, not for me, actually,
摧毁时，他们的世界就彻底崩溃了。这个故事，基本上不是我们小时候听到的那个故事，就是彻底的灭绝。而灭绝就是这个词。我的意思是，美国将军们相当自由地谈论消灭印第安人，而他们的人往往表现出令人震惊的野蛮。这确实是那种仍然被浪漫神话稍微掩盖的故事，不是吗？嗯，奇怪的是，对我来说不是，实际上
because actually the destruction of the buffalo bison whatever you want to call them is is for me it's it's the probably the thing that more than anything else haunts me um when i uh when i went to to uh to white to wyoming um they they have they have them in in yellowstone national park and that more than anything else was what i wanted to see i wanted to see them moving um and the scale of the ruin the scale of of the destruction is just monstrous and the accounts that you get i mean essentially it's the railroad that opens it up isn't it because suddenly the hunters insufficient volume to get out and wipe these you know herds of millions yeah it's
因为实际上野牛的毁灭，无论你怎么称呼它们，对我来说，它是，它可能是最让我困扰的事情，嗯，当我，嗯，我去，去，去怀俄明州时，他们，他们有，他们在黄石国家公园里有它们，那比其他任何事情都更让我想要看到，我想看到它们移动，而且毁灭的规模，破坏的规模简直是巨大的，而且你得到的记录，我的意思是本质上是铁路打开了它，不是吗？因为突然间猎人们有足够的数量出去消灭这些，你知道，数百万的牛群，是的，它是
available and you have these terrible stories of people riding along in the in the carriages with their their rifles just shooting all the buffering that they see and then terrible accounts of the of people moving out and having to pour water on the rifles to to um stop because they've got so hot and then when they run out of water urinating on them oh god and the mania for slaughter the yeah you know the volume of hides that get sent back to the east for carpets and conveyor belts and whatever and the the bone being crushed up into fertilizer and then there's nothing and there's this this terrible story of, I think, in the 1920s, that there's a settler farm somewhere in Montana or something. And one day, a buffalo walks into town.
可用的，而且你有这些可怕的故事，人们坐在马车里，用他们的步枪射击他们看到的所有野牛，然后有关于人们走出去，不得不往步枪上倒水来，嗯，停止，因为它们太热了，然后当他们没水时，在上面小便的可怕记录，哦，上帝，屠杀的狂热，是的，你知道，运回东部做地毯和传送带等等的皮毛数量，骨头被压碎成肥料，然后什么都没有了，而且有这个，这个可怕的故事，我想，在1920年代，蒙大拿州或其他地方有个定居者农场。有一天，一头野牛走进镇子。
And it's like everyone in the town goes, what is this? You know, they know what it is, but it's a legend to them. It's like a ghost has appeared. So the whole town comes and stands around this buffalo. And they just stare at it. And they stare at it for about 20 minutes. and they don't know what to do with it. So a guy gets a gun and shoots it. Oh, God.
就像镇上的每个人都说，这是什么？你知道，他们知道它是什么，但它对他们来说是一个传说。就像一个鬼魂出现了。所以整个镇子的人都围着这头野牛站着。他们只是盯着它看。他们盯着它看了大约20分钟。他们不知道该拿它怎么办。所以一个家伙拿了一把枪把它射杀了。哦，上帝。
I knew that was going to happen. That's so depressing. That's unbelievable. And, of course, the same thing happens to the beavers. Yeah. The scale of environmental destruction that the Westward expansion of the United States brings, I think, is devastating. I mean, to some extent. It focuses what happens wherever European settlers move.
我知道会发生这种事。这太令人沮丧了。这简直难以置信。当然，海狸也发生了同样的事情。是的。我认为美国向西扩张带来的环境破坏规模是毁灭性的。我的意思是，在某种程度上。它聚焦了无论欧洲定居者走到哪里都会发生的事情。
Yeah. It really focuses it. It's a story about capitalism, isn't it, to some extent? You'd expect this from a Marxist historian like me, of course, Tom. But it's a story about the cost of capitalism. Stephen Cook has a question picking up on something you said about railroads. He says, did the railroad tame the Wild West? And clearly, I think the railroad played a huge part. So the sort of, in some ways, the heyday of the Wild West, I mean, the Old West period, I suppose, runs from, well, I mean,
是的。它确实聚焦了它。这是一个关于资本主义的故事，不是吗，在某种程度上？你当然会从像我这样的马克思主义历史学家那里期待这一点，汤姆。但这是一个关于资本主义代价的故事。斯蒂芬·库克有一个问题，提到了你关于铁路所说的一些事情。他说，铁路驯服了狂野西部吗？显然，我认为铁路扮演了巨大的角色。所以，在某种程度上，狂野西部的全盛时期，我的意思是，旧西部时期，我想是从，嗯，我的意思是，
it runs from American independence through to the end of the 19th century. But the kind of heyday of it is the years around the Civil War and just after the Civil War, sort of 1860s, 1870s, 1880s. And that is, of course, as you said, the age of railroad expansion. So you have these kind of Union Pacific lines and so on, these colossal lines that are carrying people across the US. But it's not just, I mean, that would have happened with or without the railroads because it happened with the wagon trains and all these trails and all that sort of thing.
它从美国独立一直持续到19世纪末。但它的全盛时期是内战前后和内战刚结束后的几年，大约是1860年代、1870年代、1880年代。当然，正如你所说，那是铁路扩张的时代。所以你有这些联合太平洋线路等等，这些巨大的线路载着人们穿越美国。但这不仅仅是，我的意思是，即使没有铁路也会发生这种情况，因为马车队和所有这些小径以及所有这类事情都发生了。
And as you say, I think profit, the desire for profit is a big part of this. But the question that sort of nags at me is where we've talked about so often in this podcast about counterfactuals and inevitability. And there's a great what if at the beginning of this period. So in 1812, after the 1812 war, when the British and the... It was 1814, so the British and the Americans have had their war
正如你所说，我认为利润，对利润的渴望是其中的很大一部分。但那个困扰我的问题是，我们在本播客中经常谈论的反事实和必然性。在这个时期开始时有一个伟大的“如果”。所以1812年，1812年战争之后，当英国人和……那是1814年，所以英国人和美国人进行了战争
and they're trying to get a peace treaty. And the British wanted an Indian buffer state in what's now the upper Midwest. And the Americans said no, because they already had their eyes on it and they'd sort of earmarked it for expansion. And I wonder if some kind of Indian state and a kind of British patronage had been created, whether we'd be telling this story in the same way. But of course, the Americans wouldn't count on such a state for obvious reasons. I don't think that was ever possible because I don't think it was within the remit even of an American government that was willing to sign that to agree to it. Because essentially, if you look at what happens in the 1840s, basically, the process of westward expansion runs away from the federal government.
他们试图达成和平条约。英国人想要在现在的美国中西部北部建立一个印第安缓冲国。美国人说不，因为他们已经盯上了它，并且已经为扩张预留了它。我想如果建立某种印第安国家和某种英国的赞助，我们是否会以同样的方式讲述这个故事。但当然，美国人出于显而易见的原因不会指望这样的国家。我不认为那曾经是可能的，因为我不认为即使是一个愿意签署协议的美国政府，其职权范围也包括同意这一点。因为本质上，如果你看看1840年代发生了什么，基本上，向西扩张的过程脱离了联邦政府的控制。
So you've got the war against Mexico, which is incredibly brutal. That's the backdrop for Cormac McCarthy's great novel, Blood Meridian, which is a terrifying portrayal. Yeah, we talked about that in the historical fiction podcast, didn't we? And that essentially is organised by gangs of vigilantes. And it's one that the United States then piggybacks onto. But also you've got the gold rush and 1848 you know there's nothing yeah so there's nothing that that any federal government could do to stop people going on that gold rush um no the government's simply not powerful enough to control yeah as you say i mean it doesn't have the institutional resources
所以你有针对墨西哥的战争，这极其残酷。那是科马克·麦卡锡的伟大小说《血色子午线》的背景，那是一个可怕的描绘。是的，我们在历史小说播客中谈论过那个，不是吗？而那本质上是由治安维持者团伙组织的。这是美国随后跟进的。但你也有淘金热和1848年，你知道，没有什么，是的，所以没有什么联邦政府能做来阻止人们去参加那场淘金热，嗯，不，政府根本没有足够的力量来控制，是的，正如你所说，我的意思是它没有制度资源
doesn't have the manpower actually yeah yeah and and then of course you've got the the the civil war which again means that vast reaches of the west essentially are beyond federal control yeah so you got the the texas rangers who you know played prominent role in the in in the war against mexico and then particularly against the comanches they go back and fight on the side of the confederacy and that's where the west really becomes wild because it's an absolute free-for-all there is a the civil war and the wild west kind of bleed into each other and that's one thing that you get from um so people who don't know much about the civil war
没有人力，实际上，是的，是的，然后当然你有内战，这意味着西部的广大地区本质上超出了联邦的控制，是的，所以你有德克萨斯骑警，你知道，在针对墨西哥的战争中扮演了重要角色，然后特别是针对科曼奇人，他们回去并在邦联一边作战，那就是西部真正变得狂野的地方，因为那绝对是一场混战，内战和狂野西部在某种程度上相互渗透，这是你从，嗯，所以那些不太了解内战的人会得到的一件事
but or the wild west but have seen dancers with wolves will get a sense of this because kevin costner is his character is a civil war veteran as so many of the the soldiers and indeed the scouts and the sort of these classic figures you know sort of the wild bill hickox and the buffalo bill coders i mean a lot of them have been involved in general custer yeah custer is a classic custer of in a cavalry officer hadn't in the civil war and his career had gone nowhere afterwards he'd fallen out with president grant ulysses s grant former civil War general who'd become president. And he was basically trying to revive his political career, Custer, when he goes off on this doomed attempt. Well, I think, I mean, I think Custer, actually, I mean, he just loves it, doesn't he?
或者狂野西部，但看过《与狼共舞》的人会对此有所了解，因为凯文·科斯特纳的角色是一名内战老兵，正如许多士兵，实际上还有侦察兵和这类经典人物，你知道，像狂野比尔·希科克和布法罗·比尔·科迪，我的意思是他们中的许多人都参与了，卡斯特将军，是的，卡斯特是典型的卡斯特，在内战中是一名骑兵军官，之后他的职业生涯就没落了，他与格兰特总统闹翻了，尤利西斯·S·格兰特，前内战将军，后来成为了总统。他基本上是在试图重振他的政治生涯，卡斯特，当他去进行这次注定的尝试时。嗯，我想，我的意思是，我想卡斯特，实际上，我的意思是，他只是喜欢它，不是吗？
He loves the West. He thinks it's fun. He relishes the excitement of it all. I can't believe you're speaking up for custer tom i never saw this coming well custer's a terrible man really he is a terrible man but he's also a charismatic man because he enjoys everything that he does and yeah so when he when he gets told by uh grant that he can't go with his you know with the seventh cavalry he he basically falls down on his knees before general terry kind of begs him and and that's it and there's a it's it's the kind of
他喜欢西部。他认为这很有趣。他享受这一切的兴奋。我不敢相信你在为卡斯特辩护，汤姆，我没想到会这样。嗯，卡斯特确实是个可怕的人，他确实是个可怕的人，但他也是一个有魅力的人，因为他享受他所做的一切，是的，所以当他被格兰特告知他不能带着他的，你知道，第七骑兵队去时，他基本上跪在特里将军面前，某种程度上乞求他，就是这样，而且有一种，这是一种
the flamboyance and the histrionics of custer that i think people actually really respond to he's a he's a much loved figure among the mill i mean he has a lot of enemies but he's also very loved and i think that part of of what makes custer success, and he is a success right the way up to Little Bighorn, is that he's the kind of the model of what every cavalryman would like to be. He's a creature of whim and impulse whose reaction to a buffalo is to go off and shoot it, to seeing a war band of Indians is to charge it. And essentially there's this fantastic from Sitting Bull who was not at Little Bighorn, but was asked to say, you know, what,
卡斯特的浮夸和表演欲，我认为人们实际上真的很回应。他在军队中是一个很受欢迎的人物，我的意思是，他有很多敌人，但他也非常受欢迎，而且我认为卡斯特成功的一部分，而且他一直到小大角战役都是成功的，是他那种每个骑兵都想成为的典范。他是一个反复无常和冲动的人，他对野牛的反应是去射杀它，看到一队印第安人就冲锋。本质上，有一个来自坐牛的奇妙故事，他不在小大角战役现场，但被要求说，你知道，什么，
what, what, what do people who fought at Little Bighorn say? How did Custer die? And he says, well, the very last thing that Custer did as he died was first to kill someone and then to burst out laughing.
什么，什么，什么在小大角战役中战斗的人怎么说？卡斯特是怎么死的？他说，嗯，卡斯特死前做的最后一件事首先是杀了一个人，然后放声大笑。
And that's how he died. That is basically, you know, but, but there is a kind of charisma there but before we go to a break time which i want to do in a bit i'll just say one thing which i think you've absolutely picked up on which is celebrity custer was a celebrity custer took journalists with him on his on his expeditions and he manicured his image in the papers and actually this whole subject of the West, one reason that it's such a great subject, and it's been so glamorised, and it's been so debated, is that it is wrapped up from the outset of the Civil War-ish period, the sort of heyday of the Wild West,
他就是那样死的。这基本上是，你知道，但是，但是那里有一种魅力，但在我们休息之前，汤姆，我想做一点，我只想说一件事，我认为你绝对抓住了这一点，那就是名人。卡斯特是一个名人，卡斯特带着记者去他的探险队，他在报纸上精心打造自己的形象，实际上这个关于西部的整个主题，它之所以是一个如此伟大的主题，并且被如此美化，并且被如此辩论，是因为它从内战时期开始，也就是狂野西部的全盛时期，
with photography, with dime novels, with journalism, and with Wild West shows and all those kinds of things. So Sitting Bull appears in shows, in kind of reenactments. And actually, almost all of these people that we've talked about are engaged in the media. So they're either putting on shows for the public or they're writing, Custer writes stories in the papers. And that's what makes it such a great subject.
就与摄影、廉价小说、新闻业以及狂野西部表演和所有这些东西纠缠在一起。所以坐牛出现在表演中，在某种重演中。实际上，我们谈论的几乎所有这些人都在从事媒体工作。所以他们要么是在为公众表演，要么是在写作，卡斯特在报纸上写故事。这就是使它成为一个如此伟大主题的原因。
And the exception that proves the rule, the one celebrity from the Wild West who is never photographed is Crazy Horse. Yeah. Who in a way is the most kind of charismatic figure of the lot, precisely because of that. And although he dies in a kind of squalid reservation brawl, his body then gets spirited away and nobody knows where it's buried. But that obviously, that's the that's the legend isn't it that's so he's the king arthur of of the wild west and and the whole thing of that you know he will come again there's this um a kind
而证明这一规则的例外，狂野西部中从未被拍照的名人是疯马。是的。他在某种程度上是其中最有魅力的人物，恰恰是因为这一点。虽然他死于一场肮脏的保留地斗殴，但他的尸体随后被秘密运走，没人知道他被埋在哪里。但那显然，那是，那是传说，不是吗？所以他是狂野西部的亚瑟王，而且关于那件事的整个事情，你知道，他会再来，有这个，嗯，一种
of fascinating example of how of of the contest between the the westward imperial expansion of the united states and the reluctance of people like crazy horse to be memorialized is this incredible kind of statue wars that's going on in the black hills you know so you've got mount rushmore obviously with the with the sculptures of the four presidents but then you've got this um this polish sculptor who's over the course of his life trying to sculpt a huge statue of crazy oh yeah i've seen. Would be the second largest statue in the world. But is hugely contested because a lot of, you know, the Iglaagla Lakota people say, well, you know,
迷人的例子，关于美国向西的帝国扩张与像疯马这样的人不愿被纪念之间的竞争，就是这个在黑山正在进行的令人难以置信的某种雕像战争，你知道，所以你有拉什莫尔山，显然有四位总统的雕塑，但然后你有这个，嗯，这个波兰雕塑家，他一生都在试图雕刻一座巨大的疯马雕像，哦，是的，我见过。将是世界上第二大雕像。但它受到了巨大的争议，因为很多，你知道，伊格拉格拉拉科塔人说，嗯，你知道，
the whole point about Crazy Horse, he wasn't photographed, we don't know where he's buried. Don't do this. Such a good story. Great stuff. All right, Tom, listen, it's time to get off your horse and drink your milk. There's a saloon bar in town and I fancy me three fingers of bourbon.
关于疯马的全部意义在于，他没有被拍照，我们不知道他被埋在哪里。别做这个。真是个好故事。太棒了。好了，汤姆，听着，是时候从马上下来喝你的牛奶了。镇上有个沙龙酒吧，我想喝三指深的波本威士忌。
Who writes this stuff? Anyway, we're off for a break. We'll see you in a minute or two. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. and on our Q&A,
谁写的这些东西？总之，我们要去休息一下。我们一两分钟后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to the rest is history with me dominic sandbrook and tom holland and a reminder that on wednesday the 21st of april we will be doing this podcast live on the internet everybody
我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克和汤姆·霍兰德，提醒大家，在4月21日星期三，我们将会在互联网上直播这个播客，每个人
is welcome it's free to join and we will be talking about assassinations failed and successful and we'll put out a link on twitter a few days beforehand and this thursday we are talking as if one holland wasn't bad enough we've got a veritable united provinces we've got a netherlands very good dominic very good tom's tom's brother james who knows more about the Second World War than just about anybody, is coming on on Thursday, and he will be talking about 1940, perhaps the most consequential, the most mythologized year in recent history. So that's something to look forward to. Now, Tom, let's get into the myth. So we've got a couple of questions here. We've got a question from Anand. What was the West really like? can we separate fact from fiction and that kind of tallies with julian hoffman's question which is about the history of westerns is it more influential than the actual history of the west
都受欢迎，加入是免费的，我们将讨论失败和成功的暗杀，我们会在几天前在推特上发布一个链接，这个星期四我们正在讨论，好像一个霍兰德还不够糟糕，我们有一个真正的联合省，我们有一个荷兰，非常好，多米尼克，非常好，汤姆的，汤姆的兄弟詹姆斯，他比任何人都更了解第二次世界大战，星期四要来，他将谈论1940年，也许是近代史上最重要、最被神话的一年。所以这值得期待。现在，汤姆，让我们进入神话。所以我们这里有几个问题。我们有一个来自阿南德的问题。西部到底是什么样的？我们能把事实和虚构分开吗？这与朱利安·霍夫曼关于西部片历史的问题相吻合，它是比西部的实际历史更有影响力吗？
of course in many ways it it is so tom fact and fiction um you're a great devotee of the fiction aren't you the kind of myth of the west yes um i think i think i mean i think in a way yeah i definitely just as the myth of king arthur is probably more important than whatever the you know if it even existed the the uh the bedrock of fact um i i think that the myth of the western has been hugely influential hasn't it on on 20th century america and on the way that america is understood i think it's absolutely central in america's self-image i mean this there was an argument so something that all people who do sort of american history um at university learn is about frederick jackson turner's frontier thesis so he yes he presented this so where are you on that actually and so alex massey distinguished um journalist actually
当然，在许多方面，它确实是，所以汤姆，事实和虚构，嗯，你是虚构的忠实拥护者，不是吗？那种西部的神话，是的，嗯，我想，我想，我的意思是，我想在某种程度上，是的，我绝对，就像亚瑟王的神话可能比无论它（如果它真的存在的话）的事实基础更重要一样，嗯，我，我认为西部片的神话对20世纪的美国以及美国被理解的方式产生了巨大的影响，不是吗？我认为它在美国的自我形象中绝对是核心，我的意思是，有一个论点，所以所有在大学里做某种美国历史的人都学过弗雷德里克·杰克逊·特纳的边疆论，所以他，是的，他提出了这个，所以你对此有什么看法？实际上，亚历克斯·马西，杰出的，嗯，记者，实际上
asked about that he said um you know, what's the current state of academic thinking on that? Dominic, what is the current state of academic thinking on that? So in 1893, I think it is, Frederick Jackson Turner, who's an American historian, presents this paper, or he writes this paper. And he basically says, the US census has declared that the frontier is closed, that America has been completely opened up. There is no Wild West anymore. And he writes this paper basically saying the frontier is key to America. It's what makes America different from Europe.
问了那个，他说，嗯，关于那个的学术思想现状是什么？多米尼克，关于那个的学术思想现状是什么？所以1893年，我想是这样，弗雷德里克·杰克逊·特纳，他是一位美国历史学家，提出了这篇论文，或者他写了这篇论文。他基本上说，美国人口普查已经宣布边疆关闭了，美国已经完全开放了。不再有狂野西部了。他写了这篇论文，基本上说边疆对美国是关键。这就是使美国不同于欧洲的原因。
This is the point at which Americans are sort of straining for a sense of national identity and a sense of distinctiveness from Europe. And he says it's the frontier, and it gives you democracy. It gives you freedom. It's very violent, it gives you self-reliance, and all these things make America different from Europe. And the frontier is key to our identity. And ever since historians have argued how true this is, and of course there's lots of historians who have disagreed with it,
这是美国人努力寻找民族认同感和与欧洲区别感的时候。他说这是边疆，它给了你民主。它给了你自由。它非常暴力，它给了你自力更生，所有这些东西使美国不同于欧洲。边疆对我们的身份至关重要。从那时起，历史学家们就一直在争论这是多么真实，当然有很多历史学家不同意这一点，
I actually think America clearly is a society shaped by the experience of the frontier. I mean, the American relationship with guns is only really explicable if you think about the violence of so much North American history. And, of course, there's more to American history than just the frontier, but I think it does make sense.
我实际上认为美国显然是一个被边疆经验塑造的社会。我的意思是，只有当你考虑到北美历史中如此多的暴力时，美国与枪支的关系才是可以解释的。当然，美国历史不仅仅是边疆，但我认为它确实有道理。
What do you think, Tom? Well, also the myth of self-sufficiency, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. So, Andrew Jackson, who we talked about the myth of self-sufficiency, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. The idea that you go and live in a log cabin. So Andrew Jackson, who we talked about the War of 1812, that was his great victory against the British. I mean, he defined himself as a frontiersman. He kind of ended up in Nashville, I think, didn't he?
你觉得呢，汤姆？嗯，还有自给自足的神话，不是吗？是的，完全正确。所以，安德鲁·杰克逊，我们谈论过自给自足的神话，不是吗？是的，完全正确。那种你去住木屋的想法。所以安德鲁·杰克逊，我们谈论过1812年战争，那是他对抗英国人的伟大胜利。我的意思是，他把自己定义为边疆人。他最终在纳什维尔，我想，不是吗？
And Lincoln. Lincoln and his log cabin. And Lincoln is, yeah, the classic example. The sort of self-made man. I think that's absolutely central to American identity. And masculinity, which you talked about earlier on. the idea of the frontiersman the cowboy i mean the cowboy is such a huge figure in american popular culture i guess i guess that um that the the criticism of of the idea of there being a single frontier is that actually there are multiple frontiers and in fact there are often so many frontiers that it makes better sense really to think of it as a kind of you know a kind of zone of of of exchange because as well
还有林肯。林肯和他的木屋。林肯是，是的，典型的例子。那种白手起家的人。我认为这对美国身份绝对是核心。还有男性气质，你之前谈到的。边疆人、牛仔的想法，我的意思是，牛仔是美国流行文化中如此巨大的形象，我想，我想，嗯，对存在单一边疆这一想法的批评是，实际上有多个边疆，事实上往往有这么多边疆，以至于把它看作一种，你知道，一种，嗯，一种交流区，因为除了
as as yankees and native americans you've got canadians you've got french you've got mexicans you've got people from all kinds of different traditions all kind of meeting up and i guess for much of the 19th century the what we the west is a kind of zone where all of these are meeting yeah that makes it so it is it is the kind of classic um sort of border zone the sort of melting pot isn't it so i mean a lot of cowboys there were black cowboys you know asian americans there were you know lots of of mexicans it's it the sort of image of the john wayne stagecoach kind of image the searchers is not chinese laborers building the the railroads um yeah and of course the other thing to remember is that um the uh the native american tribes are also
扬基人和美洲原住民之外，你还有加拿大人，你有法国人，你有墨西哥人，你有来自各种不同传统的人，都在某种程度上相遇，而且我想在19世纪的大部分时间里，我们所说的西部是一个所有这些都在相遇的区域，是的，这使它，所以它是，它是那种经典的，嗯，某种边界区，某种大熔炉，不是吗？所以我的意思是，很多牛仔，有黑人牛仔，你知道，亚裔美国人，有，你知道，很多墨西哥人，它，那种约翰·韦恩驿站马车的形象，那种《搜索者》的形象，不是修建铁路的中国劳工，是的，当然，另一件要记住的事情是，嗯，美洲原住民部落也
kind of expanding it's not like you know, the myth now might be that they are rooted to the soil, that they, you know, they live in one particular place, but that's not the case. They also are expanding often eastwards. They're all kind of sweeping. So, I mean, the Comanches are, you know, they have this kind of huge,
在某种程度上扩张，并不是说，你知道，现在的神话可能是他们扎根于土壤，他们，你知道，他们生活在某个特定的地方，但事实并非如此。他们也经常向东扩张。他们都在某种程度上横扫。所以，我的意思是，科曼奇人是，你知道，他们有这种，嗯，巨大的，
I mean, you could call it an empire, couldn't you? Comanche empire. There's Comanche, people talk about the Comanche empire. Exactly exactly yeah yeah yeah so so it's it's a very contested area but of course ultimately it because it's the united states that wins out it's the idea of a united states frontier moving westwards westwards westwards and of course eastwards from california symbolized by that joining up of the two the two railroads but just on the western genre i think what's so interesting about that is that it's not completely created afterwards.
我的意思是，你可以称之为帝国，不是吗？科曼奇帝国。有科曼奇，人们谈论科曼奇帝国。完全正确，完全正确，是的，是的，是的，所以它是一个非常受争议的地区，但当然最终，因为它最终是美国赢了，所以它是美国边疆向西、向西、向西移动的想法，当然还有从加利福尼亚向东，象征着两条铁路的连接。但只是关于西部类型片，我认为关于它如此有趣的是，它并不是完全在之后创造的。
So the Wild West show, which is key in creating the romantic image of the West. So the people who do these shows, the sort of Buffalo Bills and Calamity Jane and these kinds of characters, I mean, they're doing the shows at the same time as the Wild West is still in its final stages. And it's extraordinary to think how popular those shows are.
所以狂野西部表演，这在创造西部的浪漫形象方面是关键。所以那些做这些表演的人，那种布法罗·比尔和灾星简以及这类角色，我的意思是，他们在狂野西部仍处于最后阶段时就在做这些表演。想到这些表演有多受欢迎真是太不可思议了。
So they kind of peak in the 1880s, 1890s. They're incredibly popular in Europe. So among the people, if you look into it, among the people who saw Buffalo Bill's show, the Kaiser saw it. He was a big fan. Queen Victoria saw it. Edward VII saw it. George V saw it. He was a big fan. Queen Victoria saw it. Edward VII saw it. George V saw it. I mean, this is massive entertainment for Europe's kind of,
所以它们在1880年代、1890年代达到顶峰。它们在欧洲非常受欢迎。所以，在那些人中，如果你深入研究它，在那些看过布法罗·比尔表演的人中，凯撒看了它。他是一个大粉丝。维多利亚女王看了它。爱德华七世看了它。乔治五世看了它。他是一个大粉丝。维多利亚女王看了它。爱德华七世看了它。乔治五世看了它。我的意思是，这对欧洲的某种，
not just for the sort of common man, but for the European elite. Hitler grew up reading cowboy stories and loving cowboy stories. It's extraordinary the extent to which it was embedded in the kind of western imagination between let's say 1880 and 1920 but i think even before that because i think the moment that the buffalo cleared and you have this sense of there being land up for grabs there is a kind of just a few years where all kinds of european aristocrats are going out to the west so you've got um i think churchill's aunt there's a french aristocrat who builds a
不仅仅是对于普通人，对于欧洲精英阶层也是如此。希特勒从小就读牛仔故事，也热爱牛仔故事。在1880年到1920年之间，这种西部想象力深入人心的程度令人惊叹，但我认为甚至在此之前就已经开始了，因为我认为在水牛被清理干净、人们意识到土地可以随意占有的那一刻起，就有那么几年，各种欧洲贵族纷纷前往西部，所以你有，我想丘吉尔的姑妈，还有一位法国贵族建造了一座
chateau the the red baron's grandfather moves out there that's a good i didn't know that very very fleetingly they and then of course you know it all goes wrong because the terrible winter all the cattle get wiped out and people start putting up barbed wire fence and everything and then you have dust bowls and stuff and essentially the west becomes an empty an empty space a flyover zone but um that of course is what what then it because it's empty it's possible then to project fantasy back onto it well let's just say something before we get into lots of questions a quick um a nice pub quiz fact for you tom do you know what the first western was the first western film it's not the one that um wyatt eep advised on no no no no no tell me so do you want to know and give me do you want to know where it was filmed
城堡，红男爵的祖父也搬到了那里，这很好，我以前不知道，他们只是非常短暂地在那里待过，然后当然，你知道一切都搞砸了，因为可怕的冬天，所有的牛都被消灭了，人们开始竖起铁丝网围栏等等，然后出现了沙尘暴之类的东西，本质上西部变成了一个空旷的空间，一个被遗忘的区域，但嗯，那当然就是，因为它空旷，所以才有可能将幻想投射回它身上，好吧，在我们进入大量问题之前，先说点什么，给你一个不错的酒吧问答题，汤姆，你知道第一部西部片是什么吗？第一部西部电影，不是那部嗯怀亚特·厄普担任顾问的，不不不不不，告诉我，所以你想知道吗，给我，你想知道它是在哪里拍摄的吗？
probably i think it was i do know this it was filmed in the lake district wasn't it it was filmed in blackburn in lancashire yes yes i did know that yes so it's a film called you can see it online it's called kidnapping by ind. So it's a film called, you can see it online, it's called Kidnapping by Indians. And it was a film by Mitchell and Kenyon, the great sort of cinema pioneers. So it's filmed in Blackburn in 1903 and it's the first Western movie. It's a minute long.
可能，我想我知道，它是在湖区拍摄的，对吧？它是在兰开夏郡的布莱克本拍摄的，是的，是的，我确实知道，是的，所以这是一部电影，你可以在网上看到它，它叫《印第安人绑架案》。所以这是一部电影，你可以在网上看到它，它叫《印第安人绑架案》。这是米切尔和凯尼恩的作品，他们是伟大的电影先驱。所以它于1903年在布莱克本拍摄，是第一部西部电影。它只有一分钟长。
And there's a sort of a woman with her baby or a toddler and a couple of Indians attack her and then a cowboy appears and fights them off and then that's the end of the story. But that in itself tells you just how international this was right from the very beginning. You know, obviously later on you have the spaghetti westerns of Sergio Leone and so on, but even at the beginning...
有一个女人带着她的婴儿或蹒跚学步的孩子，几个印第安人袭击了她，然后一个牛仔出现并击退了他们，故事就结束了。但这本身就告诉你，从一开始这就是多么国际化。你知道，显然后来有了塞尔吉奥·莱昂内的意大利西部片等等，但即使在最初……
But doesn't it also, does it not also point out what, in a sense we were talking about right at the beginning, which is that actually to understand the West, you have to imagine yourself back into a world where you could be kidnapped by Indians. And, you know, if you get kidnapped by the Comanche, you know, it's going to be pretty horrible. You know that, you know, you're going to be buried up to your neck and have your eyelids cut off or have your testicles cut off and stuffed in your mouth. I mean, it's all fairly unspeakable stuff and so the element of danger of real jeopardy then of course once that sense of
但这难道不也指出了我们一开始讨论的某种东西吗，那就是实际上要理解西部，你必须把自己想象回到一个你可能会被印第安人绑架的世界。而且，你知道，如果你被科曼奇人绑架了，你知道，那会非常可怕。你知道，你知道，你会被埋到脖子，眼皮被割掉，或者睾丸被割掉塞进嘴里。我的意思是，这一切都相当难以启齿，所以危险的因素，真正的危险，当然一旦那种
danger jeopardy has gone it provides a perfect stage for film i mean that it does and i think as well the wild west don't you think though tom that the wild west also flourishes i mean this is also the period when tolkien is writing and when kind of medievalism is super popular and in other words the wild west is is a is a legend created for people who live in cities who who who you know they they don't see the great plains they don't live in communion with nature they don't get out you know they don't get out of their factories and their offices very much and this it's a bit like the boy scouts in a way you know baden powells and the romance of kind of king solomon's mines and all these sort of british imperial adventure stories it's
危险和危险感消失了，它就为电影提供了一个完美的舞台，我的意思是它确实如此，而且我也认为，你不觉得吗，汤姆，狂野西部也蓬勃发展，我的意思是这也是托尔金写作的时期，也是中世纪主义非常流行的时期，换句话说，狂野西部是为生活在城市里的人创造的传说，他们，你知道，他们看不到大平原，他们不与自然交流，他们不出去，你知道，他们不怎么离开工厂和办公室，这在某种程度上有点像童子军，你知道贝登堡和《所罗门王的宝藏》之类的浪漫故事，以及所有这些英国帝国冒险故事，它是
escapism for people for an increasingly urban population that's what i say we've got a dominant we've got a question here from salva uh derfusich uh who says what is it about this period that led to the creation of the mythic cowboy gunslinger and why throughout our culture has this warrior legend become so enduring so i think in a way you've you've you know you've basically answered that but although it also the gunslinger your point but your point about masculinity tom there's a lot of that in it isn't there the gunslinger don't you think i mean there's a sort of the clint eastwood sort of stereotype or the john wayne stereotype of this sort of taciturn granite jawed figure i mean is it
为日益城市化的人口提供的逃避现实的手段，这就是我要说的，我们有一个来自萨尔瓦·德尔富西奇的问题，他问是什么导致了这个时期创造了神话般的牛仔枪手，为什么在我们的文化中，这个战士传说变得如此持久，所以我认为在某种程度上你已经，你知道，你基本上已经回答了这个问题，尽管它也，枪手，你的观点，但你关于男子气概的观点，汤姆，其中有很多，不是吗，枪手，你不觉得吗，我的意思是有一种克林特·伊斯特伍德式的刻板印象，或者约翰·韦恩式的这种沉默寡言、下巴坚毅的人物，我的意思是，这是
coincidence that that emerges at the time when the women's suffrage movement is taking off you know when men are seeming maybe more feminized i don't know so so that's that's why i think almost the most interesting western i don't and you as an american specialist i don't know whether you agree with this but but as a kind of mirror held up to American culture would be High Noon. Because the plot of High Noon is, you know, there's a bunch of bandits who are riding down on the town to gun down the sheriff who'd put away the leader of the bandits who's been let out of prison. And he is Quaker bride, and they're due to go off and enjoy their
巧合吗，它出现在妇女选举权运动兴起的时候，你知道，当男人看起来似乎更加女性化时，我不知道，所以这就是为什么我认为几乎最有趣的西部片，我不知道，作为一名美国专家，我不知道你是否同意这一点，但作为一面映照美国文化的镜子，那应该是《正午》。因为《正午》的情节是，你知道，有一群强盗骑马来到镇上，要枪杀那个把强盗头目关进监狱的警长，而那个头目刚被释放。他有一位贵格会新娘，他们本该去享受他们的
honeymoon but he feels that he has to stay in the town and and defend it and the quaker bride uh grace kelly um says you know if you if you do this i'm going to leave you and her husband the the the marshal uh played by gary cooper insists on saying because he feels that that's his duty um and it's this that then makes it's basically it's ronald reagan's favorite film and bill clinton's and interesting you mentioned tony soprano is tony soprano's film and tony soprano is tony soprano is kind of saying i want you know why aren't people strong and silent like gary cooper anymore uh and for for Reagan and Clinton, it's about overcoming, you know, because the townspeople in High Noon
蜜月，但他觉得他必须留在镇上并保卫它，他的贵格会新娘，嗯，格蕾丝·凯利，嗯，说，你知道，如果你这样做，我就离开你，她的丈夫，嗯，由加里·库珀饰演的警长，坚持说，因为他觉得那是他的职责，嗯，正是这一点使得，它基本上是罗纳德·里根最喜欢的电影，也是比尔·克林顿的，有趣的是你提到了托尼·索普拉诺，这是托尼·索普拉诺的电影，托尼·索普拉诺是在说，我想要，你知道，为什么人们不再像加里·库珀那样坚强而沉默了，嗯，对于里根和克林顿来说，这是关于克服，你知道，因为《正午》里的镇民
are feckless and cowardly and won't back him. It's about doing the right thing in the face of everything. Both Hitler and Stalin loved Westerns, Tom. So that sort of, there's something about that, isn't there, about the sort of the male hero, the defying, you know, defying, I guess. But there's also a sense of doom that hangs over a lot of these hero the defying you know defying i guess but there's also a sense of doom that hangs over a lot of these westerns because you know that not only is maybe the protagonist potentially doomed but the world is doomed as well i think that was what gives it this
是软弱无能和懦弱的，不会支持他。这是关于在面对一切时做正确的事。希特勒和斯大林都喜欢西部片，汤姆。所以那种，关于那种男性英雄，那种反抗，你知道，反抗，我想。但这些西部片中也笼罩着一种厄运感，因为你知道，不仅主角可能注定要失败，而且世界也注定要失败，我认为这就是赋予它这种
sort of romantic edge don't you think yes and again it's it's the sense that this masculine age of heroism is actually threatened by what is often cast as the kind of feminizing impulses of peace. So the Grace Kelly figure in High Noon, she's kind of persuaded that actually it's her duty to stand by her man. You know, do not forsake me, oh my darling, the famous song. And she ends up shooting the baddie in the back. But if she hadn't, then, you know, the marshal would be shot. It's also the plot, Tom, of Once Upon a Time in the West. So Sergio Leone's great film. So the woman is the protagonist.
浪漫色彩的原因，你不觉得吗？是的，再一次，这是一种感觉，这种男性英雄主义时代实际上受到了通常被视为和平的女性化冲动的影响。所以《正午》中的格蕾丝·凯利形象，她被说服了，实际上支持她的男人是她的职责。你知道，“不要抛弃我，哦，亲爱的”，那首著名的歌。她最终从背后射杀了坏人。但如果她没有，那么，你知道，警长就会被枪杀。这也是《西部往事》的情节，汤姆。塞尔吉奥·莱昂内的伟大电影。所以女人是主角。
Claudia Cardinale is the protagonist. There's the coming of the railroad. All the sort of old gunslingers basically end up dead. Henry Fonda and go. And she is left alone at the end, basically. She is now the defining person who's going to sort of rule the West. The railroad has come. The old age is gone. And that's part of, I think, that sort of sense of a vanished age,
克劳迪娅·卡汀娜是主角。铁路来了。所有那些老枪手基本上都死了。亨利·方达等等。最后只剩下她一个人，基本上。她现在是决定统治西部的人。铁路来了。旧时代结束了。我认为这是那种消失的时代感的一部分，
of a lost age of chivalry. And chivalry often sort of plays a part in these things. There's a kind of, I think that you can map on to the stories of the Old West, like High Noon and like The Searchers or Stagecoach or whatever. Stories about knights, stories about the hero in shining armor and so again to go back to owen wister and the virginian i mean he was kind of overtly racist in his sense that the anglo-saxon race were this kind of you know they were the night original knights errant and that in a sense inferior races had to be cleared out of the way which would include you know mexicans as well as native americans um and i think that that's another kind of element in the cultural development of the Wild West myth that makes it obviously furiously contested at the moment.
一个失落的骑士精神时代。骑士精神通常在这些事情中扮演角色。我认为你可以将旧西部的故事，比如《正午》和《搜索者》或《驿马车》等等，映射到骑士的故事上，关于闪亮盔甲中的英雄的故事，所以再次回到欧文·威斯特和《弗吉尼亚人》，我的意思是，他在某种意义上是公开的种族主义者，认为盎格鲁-撒克逊种族是这种，你知道，他们是最初的游侠骑士，在某种意义上，劣等种族必须被清除，这包括，你知道，墨西哥人以及美洲原住民，嗯，我认为这是狂野西部神话文化发展中的另一个元素，这使得它显然在目前受到激烈的争议。
Let's do some questions. Let's do some questions. Do you want to pick one? Well, that's an interesting one from Gregory Doyle. How different were the American and Canadian experiences of the Wild West? Because, of course, Canada had a Wild West as well. Are the gunslinging sheriffs versus the unarmed Mounties both caric Wild West? Because of course, Canada had a Wild West as well. Are the gun-slinging sheriffs
让我们做一些问题。让我们做一些问题。你想选一个吗？嗯，格雷戈里·多伊尔的问题很有趣。美国和加拿大的狂野西部经历有何不同？因为，当然，加拿大也有狂野西部。枪手警长与手无寸铁的骑警是狂野西部的讽刺画吗？因为当然，加拿大也有狂野西部。枪手警长
versus the unarmed Mounties both caricatures or demonstrative of fundamental differences? I hope you're going to answer this, Tom, because I actually know. You've got no views on that at all? I have no views. I'm like H.A.P. Taylor
与手无寸铁的骑警是讽刺画，还是基本差异的体现？我希望你能回答这个问题，汤姆，因为我实际上知道。你对此完全没有看法吗？我没有看法。我像H.A.P.泰勒
on the very first question time when they asked him a question about housing. And he said, I have absolutely no opinion about this at all. And I've always admired him for that and looked for an opportunity to do it. And the first mention of Canada is my chance to do that. Well, Canada had a gold rush as well with the Klondike.
在第一次提问时间，当他们问他关于住房的问题时。他说，我对此完全没有意见。我一直很钦佩他这一点，并寻找机会这样做。第一次提到加拿大就是我这样做的机会。嗯，加拿大也有淘金热，克朗代克。
Yeah. And it had a frontier. I mean, and it had Native Americans. Yes. But much less heavily settled. Yeah. So Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse, after the Battle of Little Lick, Bighorn were able to retreat across the frontier and stay there. They didn't like it, but they found it so boring that they crossed back.
是的。它也有边疆。我的意思是，它也有美洲原住民。是的。但定居程度要低得多。是的。所以坐牛和疯马，在小大角战役之后，能够撤退到边境那边并留在那里。他们不喜欢那里，但他们觉得太无聊了，所以他们又回到了这边。
Basically, but having said that, so I went to a place called Drumheller, again, because it has the world's best dinosaur museum, but it also has saloons where there are bullet holes over the mirror carefully preserved so there were the occasional shootout but the klondike um that's kind of that's where the myth of the mounties essentially comes from because it's it's a classic you know there are the bordellos and the shootouts and the uh gold prospectors and everything happening there and the mounties go in and they go in and they kind of muscle it down. But also the Klondike Gold Rush is the setting for Jack London's two great novels,
基本上，但话虽如此，所以我去了一个叫德拉姆赫勒的地方，同样是因为它有世界上最好的恐龙博物馆，但它也有沙龙，镜子上小心地保存着弹孔，所以偶尔会有枪战，但克朗代克，嗯，那就是骑警神话的本质来源，因为它是经典的，你知道，那里有妓院、枪战、淘金者等等，骑警进去，他们进去，他们以某种方式控制了局面。但克朗代克淘金热也是杰克·伦敦两部伟大小说《野性的呼唤》和《白牙》的背景，
The Call of the Wild and White Fang, which is kind of brilliant explorations of that whole theme. And they're set in Canada. So I think there are Canadian dimensions to the Wild West myth. Well, not just Canadian dimensions. So Andrew Jay has a really good question. He wants to ask about Russia. He says, how does it compare with Russian expansion under the Romanov?
这是对整个主题的精彩探索。它们以加拿大为背景。所以我认为狂野西部神话有加拿大的维度。嗯，不仅仅是加拿大的维度。安德鲁·杰伊有一个很好的问题。他想问关于俄罗斯的问题。他说，它与罗曼诺夫王朝下的俄罗斯扩张相比如何？
So Russia expanding east. Both saw massive expansion. They meet to a certain extent near Alaska. Do Russians have a similar sense of manifest destiny? And I would say, absolutely, they do. That is, to me, a really interesting parallel. The Russians are expanding at pretty much exactly this point. So they're going east into Siberia, which is obviously not very settled,
所以俄罗斯向东扩张。两者都看到了大规模的扩张。他们在阿拉斯加附近在一定程度上相遇。俄罗斯人有类似的天命论感吗？我会说，绝对有。对我来说，这是一个非常有趣的平行。俄罗斯人几乎在这一时刻正在扩张。所以他们向东进入西伯利亚，那里显然定居不多，
but they're also going into Central Asia. And to some extent, the Russian equivalent of the cowboys, the Cossack. They're on the frontier. They're unregulated. They are armed. They are hyper-masculine. They're outlaws. They're freebooters all this sort of thing so you know cowboys do have analogies outside the americas yeah yep good stuff um okay well here's are we how much longer we got
但他们也进入了中亚。在某种程度上，俄罗斯版的牛仔，哥萨克。他们在边疆。他们不受监管。他们武装起来。他们是超级男性化的。他们是亡命之徒。他们是自由掠夺者，所有这些东西，所以你知道，牛仔在美国之外确实有类比，是的，是的，好东西，嗯，好吧，我们还有多少时间
are we loads of time okay well well, this is a great question. Jeff Anello, what's the stickiest myth about the Old West that is patently wrong? Gosh, that's a good question. AJP tailoring again. Yeah. No, a lot of the myths are anchored in, have a grain of truth, though, don't they? So you mentioned bordellos. I mean, bordellos,os you know they were a thing um partly to they they sprang up to there were so many miners and and cowboys obviously i suppose
我们还有很多时间，好吧，嗯，这是一个很好的问题。杰夫·阿内洛，关于旧西部最根深蒂固但显然错误的神话是什么？天哪，这是一个好问题。又是AJP泰勒。是的。不，很多神话都扎根于，有一个真理的内核，不是吗？所以你提到了妓院。我的意思是，妓院，你知道它们确实存在，嗯，部分原因是它们涌现出来，因为有太多的矿工和牛仔，显然我想
but did all the tarts have hearts well well everybody's got a heart tom surely you know that yeah yeah uh i've never met a tart without a heart that's for sure yeah um anyway on the kermit what about cowboys i think cowboys that our sense of cowboys is probably i mean being a cowboy was unbelievably boring i mean you sort of spent so much time in the saddle then you did your two roundups every year where you separated out the calves to be branded from the rest of the sort of herd um it's very grueling the cowboys are often young they're kind of they start off when they adolescents, and later on some of them are Civil War veterans. And there's much less shooting, so cowboys do carry rifles sometimes,
但所有的妓女都有心吗？嗯，嗯，每个人都有心，汤姆，你肯定知道这一点，是的，是的，我从来没见过没有心的妓女，那是肯定的，是的，嗯，无论如何，关于牛仔，我认为牛仔，我们对牛仔的感觉可能是，我的意思是，当牛仔令人难以置信地无聊，我的意思是，你花那么多时间在马鞍上，然后你每年做两次围捕，把要打烙印的小牛从牛群中分离出来，这非常艰苦，牛仔通常很年轻，他们，他们从青春期开始，后来有些人是内战老兵。而且枪击事件少得多，所以牛仔有时确实携带步枪，
but they're not the same people as the gunslingers. So often the gunslingers, who we think of as cowboys, are scouts or trappers or Civil War officers, but they're not cowboys. They're different kind of people. So I would say maybe the cowboy is the big myth. And would you expand that to say that actually the idea of cowboys and Indians is a myth?
但他们不是和枪手一样的人。所以通常我们认为的牛仔，即枪手，是侦察兵、捕兽人或内战军官，但他们不是牛仔。他们是不同类型的人。所以我可能会说牛仔是最大的神话。你会扩展到说，实际上牛仔和印第安人的想法是一个神话吗？
Because isn't the point about cowboys that the cowboys are moving the Texas Longhorns or whatever it is from up into Wyoming and Montana because the buffalo and the Indians have gone? Yeah. Basically, there isn't, you know. Yeah, so actually you're right. The cowboys, the people who really kill a lot of Indians in the army, or sort of vigilante bands, as you say, but they're not really cowboys.
因为牛仔的重点不是牛仔把德克萨斯长角牛或其他什么东西从德克萨斯赶到怀俄明州和蒙大拿州，因为水牛和印第安人已经走了吗？是的。基本上，没有，你知道。是的，所以实际上你是对的。牛仔，那些在军队中真正杀死很多印第安人的人，或者正如你所说的义务警员团伙，但他们并不是真正的牛仔。
I mean, that's not a cowboy's job. A cowboy's not there to kind of go and kill lots of Indians. A cowboy's there to look after the cattle, basically. So, yeah, you're right. The cowboys versus Indians myth is not quite right. Yeah, so maybe that one. Okay, so perhaps another one would be the idea, actually, that there are goodies and baddies in the Wild West, that there are entire groups of people with white hats and black hats.
我的意思是，那不是牛仔的工作。牛仔不是去那里杀很多印第安人的。牛仔基本上是在那里照顾牛。所以，是的，你是对的。牛仔对印第安人的神话不太正确。是的，所以也许是那个。好吧，所以也许另一个是，实际上，狂野西部有好人和坏人，有整群戴白帽子和黑帽子的人。
But that's obviously been turned on its head, hasn't it? So now there's no question. I was only reading this morning an essay by an American historian talking about how the moral lens has completely changed. So now Anglo-American capitalist settlers are often painted as uniquely bad. You know, they are just the baddies. And the Indians are sort of, you know, what are the Indians doing? They're sort of taking drugs and communing spirits and and being close to nature and stuff and and what's sort of
但这显然已经被颠覆了，不是吗？所以现在毫无疑问。我今天早上才读到一位美国历史学家的一篇文章，谈到道德视角是如何完全改变的。所以现在盎格鲁-美国资本主义定居者通常被描绘成极其邪恶。你知道，他们就是坏人。而印第安人是，你知道，印第安人在做什么？他们是在吸毒、与灵魂交流、亲近自然之类的，而什么是
slightly lost from that is the fact that the you know indian culture was often incredibly violent in a way that we would now find really quite quite off-putting well yes we mentioned that the comanche record with torture which is really quite something and terrifying. But I guess also what we think of as the Great Plains culture is very, very influenced by what Europeans are bringing. So it's dependent on the horse. It's dependent on the rifle. Again, it's that sense of there being It's dependent on the rifle. Yeah. And I think that again, it's that sense of there being a stark division isn't quite true.
稍微丢失的是，你知道，印第安文化通常非常暴力，以至于我们现在会觉得非常令人反感，嗯，是的，我们提到了科曼奇人对酷刑的记录，这确实非常令人震惊和恐惧。但我猜我们认为的大平原文化也深受欧洲人带来的东西的影响。它依赖于马。它依赖于步枪。再一次，那种感觉是，它依赖于步枪。是的。我认为再一次，那种存在鲜明分歧的感觉并不完全正确。
Both of kind of influencing the other. Cause actually a lot of Indians spend most of their time fighting each other, not fighting the white man. So, I mean, what's one reason why they are, um, why they,
两者都在某种程度上相互影响。因为实际上很多印第安人大部分时间都在互相争斗，而不是与白人争斗。所以，我的意思是，他们失败的一个原因，嗯，他们，
they fail to resist, um, American expansion is because they, you know, it's the classic story of imperialism and conquest that often the, the indigenous people spend as much time fighting each other or quarreling or thinking how they can, they can use the settlers to play against their enemies as much as they do,
他们未能抵抗，嗯，美国扩张是因为他们，你知道，这是帝国主义和征服的经典故事，通常土著人花同样多的时间互相争斗或争吵，或者思考他们如何能，他们能利用定居者来对抗他们的敌人，就像他们做的那样，
as much as they do in kind of resisting the newcomers. But actually Alex Shiphurst has this question, which is the question underlying this whole subject. Can the killing and atrocities carried out on local native populations be categorised as genocide? Or is it more nuanced? I mean, can we talk of a genocide of Native Americans? Tom, what do you think?
就像他们在某种程度上抵抗新来者一样。但实际上亚历克斯·希普赫斯特有这个问题，这是整个主题背后的问题。对当地土著人口进行的杀戮和暴行可以归类为种族灭绝吗？还是更微妙？我的意思是，我们可以谈论美洲原住民的种族灭绝吗？汤姆，你怎么看？
This is such a difficult but necessary question, I think. I think that the annihilation of the buffalo was an attempt at cultural genocide that basically pretty much worked. I don't think that, you know, they didn't want to wipe out every last Native American, but that expansion westwards with the railroad and the army moving in coincided with a kind of a cod Darwinism. It's when Darwinism is really kicking in as a kind of a cod darwinism it's it's when darwinism is really kicking in as a kind of a popular idea and then it seems to to have lent to large elements of the american elites
我认为这是一个非常困难但必要的问题。我认为水牛的灭绝是一种文化种族灭绝的尝试，基本上相当奏效。我不认为，你知道，他们不想消灭每一个美洲原住民，但随着铁路和军队的进入，向西扩张与一种伪达尔文主义相吻合。当达尔文主义真正作为一种伪达尔文主义开始流行时，它似乎已经借给了美国精英阶层的大部分人
the sense that um it was kind of you know if you like the manifest destiny yeah of the red man to retreat and be diminished before the rise of the white man and there was definitely a kind of racial component to that and um when uh when when general sheridan gave the order that the buffalo should be wiped out he was consciously set you know he had this kind of famous phrase that it would, you know, the prairies would be covered with speckled cattle and the festive cowboy. You know, there was nothing festive about it. He knew what he was doing. General Sheridan is the man, Tom, who says the only good Indian is a dead Indian.
一种感觉，嗯，这是一种，如果你愿意的话，红人的天命，在白人崛起之前撤退和减少，这绝对有一种种族成分，嗯，当谢里丹将军下令消灭水牛时，他是有意识地设定，你知道，他有这句名言，大草原将被斑点牛和喜庆的牛仔覆盖。你知道，这没什么喜庆的。他知道他在做什么。谢里丹将军就是那个人，汤姆，他说唯一的好印第安人就是死去的印第安人。
You know, it's kind of hard to – the weird thing is that for so long people would quote that as sort of almost an amusing, swashbuckling saying. Whereas now I think it's very hard. I mean, I speak as somebody who's very un-woke. I mean, I'm basically fast asleep by kind of woke standards. But I find it hard to read some of this stuff without feeling very conflicted, very moved. I think people, the weird thing with America is that people talk about America's original sin being the importation of slaves. And, of course, America is now a society suffused with arguments about the legacy of slavery and about the injustices
你知道，这很难——奇怪的是，长期以来人们会引用这句话，几乎像是一种有趣的、虚张声势的说法。而现在我认为这非常困难。我的意思是，我作为一个非常不“觉醒”的人说话。我的意思是，按照“觉醒”的标准，我基本上睡得很死。但我发现很难阅读其中一些东西而不感到非常矛盾、非常感动。我认为人们，美国奇怪的地方在于，人们谈论美国的原始罪是进口奴隶。而且，当然，美国现在是一个充斥着关于奴隶制遗产和不公正的争论的社会
that have been done to African-Americans. But for me, so many of these American states are founded on basically the extermination of their native population. I mean, I don't think you have to be terribly woke to see that and to see that as, well, not something that should be swept under the carpet. I mean, I think it is worth discussing.
对非裔美国人所做的事情。但对我来说，这么多美国州基本上是建立在消灭其土著人口的基础上的。我的意思是，我不认为你必须非常“觉醒”才能看到这一点，并将其视为，嗯，不应该被掩盖的东西。我的意思是，我认为这值得讨论。
And I think that it's possible to kind of be true to the tragedy and the horror of what happened to the Native Americans and not merely view it from the point of view of the 21st century because there were plenty of people who were horrified by what was happening and stunned by it. So when Sitting Bull is in his reservation and getting all kinds of grief from the guy running the reservation, the person who comes and tries to sort it out is Buffalo Bill Cody, who, as you said, you know, took Sitting Bull with him around the world. And there's this terrible story that when Sitting Bull gets shot, his horse has been kind of trained to do this dance routine as part of the show.
而且我认为，有可能忠实于美洲原住民所经历的悲剧和恐怖，而不仅仅是从21世纪的角度来看，因为有很多人对正在发生的事情感到震惊和惊愕。所以当坐牛在保留地里，从管理保留地的人那里得到各种痛苦时，来试图解决问题的人是布法罗·比尔·科迪，正如你所说，你知道，带着坐牛环游世界。有一个可怕的故事，当坐牛被枪杀时，他的马被训练成在表演中跳这种舞蹈。
And he hears the gunshot. And as Sitting Bull is lying there bleeding to death, the horse is doing this dance routine. And I think that, you know, Buffalo bill responded to that you know i mean he he he he sensed the the cruelty of that and the tragedy of it and and the scale of the loss and in that sense i'm burying my heart at wounding knee which is you know the the famous book that essentially recalibrated um i i don't think it's you know i think that that is that is true to the the myth of the west in the same way that the kind of more triumphalist westerns are as well i think that i
他听到了枪声。当坐牛躺在那里流血致死时，马正在跳这种舞蹈。我认为，你知道，布法罗·比尔对此做出了回应，你知道，我的意思是，他感觉到了那种残酷和悲剧，以及损失的规模，从这个意义上说，《魂归伤膝河》，这是，你知道，那本基本上重新校准了，嗯，我不认为它是，你知道，我认为那是，那是忠实于西部神话的，就像那种更胜利主义的西部片一样，我认为我
was always part of the story i think the sense of that that's you know it's it's and that's why i compared it to to homer and to um and to king arthur is that those myths are powerful because they're not just about braggadocio and, and, and violence and, and, and masculine glory. They are also about an understanding that you can't have that without destruction and ruin and death. Well,
一直都是故事的一部分，我认为那种感觉，你知道，它是，它是，这就是为什么我把它与荷马和亚瑟王相比较，那些神话之所以强大，是因为它们不仅仅是关于吹牛、暴力和男性荣耀。它们也是关于一种理解，即没有破坏、毁灭和死亡，你就无法拥有这些。嗯，
on that note, um, that's my, to my, to my braggadocio and martial glory and to Tom's destruction and death. Um, well, uh,
说到这里，嗯，那是我的，对我的，对我的吹牛和军事荣耀，以及对汤姆的破坏和死亡。嗯，好吧，嗯，
now, now I'm going to, I'm going to read out the, the jolly script ending that the producer has written just to cheer people up and he's written the wild west has been tamed time to hang up our spurs and kick off our boots this town ain't big enough for the both of us tom see you next time so if people complain this these are one note podcasts they're quite wrong because we do all kinds of emotions in the space of 60 seconds tom see you next time yeehaw thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，现在我要，我要读出制片人写的快乐剧本结尾，只是为了让人们振作起来，他写道，狂野西部已经被驯服了，是时候挂起我们的马刺，踢掉我们的靴子了，这个镇子容不下我们两个，汤姆，下次见，所以如果人们抱怨这些是一分钟的播客，他们完全错了，因为我们在60秒内做了各种情绪，汤姆，下次见，耶哈，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。